le minet n'est pas un révolté il se veut
réaliste
j'ai d'abord un consommateur qui
dépensent parfois plus de 500 francs par
mois pour s'habiller un argent qui ne
trouve le plus souvent grâce à ses
parents je pense en plus satisfaits soi
même quand on est bien habillé
c'est beaucoup
moi je passe parce que ça nous plaît
d'être d'être comme ça
[Musique]
pour alain et michel cette obsession
restent immenses terres est un moyen de
se sentir libre est privilégiée ils
vivent dans une société obsédée par le
besoin d'acquérir le maximum de biens de
consommation et parce que les adultes
appelle le standing
non ça c'est pour s'affermir j'aime bien
ma vie je m'habitue faire c'est pourquoi
pour se singulariser alain et michel
veulent donc acheter encore plus et
surtout autre chose que les autres et se
soucie vestimentaire a pris une place
tel qu'il est l'une des choses
essentielles de leur vie je sais pas
vous dire exactement
moi j'aime bien l'affirmer contre mon
père parce que ça vaut qg fois que mon
père me critiquent tout le temps en
disant oui tu devrais faire si tu
devrais dire ça alors que moi je n'ai
pas particulièrement envie c'est pour ça
qu'il veut ben premièrement il faudrait
que je fasse quelque chose de sérieux
et puis je peux enfin qui le choix
naturel passion en fait à la base
j'étais pas j'étais pas comme ça quoi ça
[Musique]
m
vous attendez beaucoup de plaisir
ils veulent s'intégrer à tout prix à la
société pour en tirer le maximum de
profit mais la plupart attendent la
solution de l'extérieur c'est la
réussite sociale c'est arrivé à avoir
beaucoup plus élevé pouvoir vivre
comment tu as envie 10 da lire je crois
peut-être avec le maximum de luxe et le
maximum de liberté en lui
à la mer
[Musique]
actu
c'est des filles avec qui vous sortez je
sais pas premièrement même bien aller
avec à dire exactement
faire ça cinq minutes mer et où j'ai
trop chaud hein
avec elle on va aller là bas pour aller
danser c'est tout ça c'est ouais
évidemment on est bien enfin je dirais
pas comment les noms mais on peut même
bien quand même aller avec alain delon
tente d'aller dans les boîtes séduire
une fille joue bien passé une nuit avec
elle ah non je crois c'est dur pour nous
parce que avoir des rapports avec une
fille
on peut quand on veut enfin c'est pas
facile mais c'est dur ça apporte une
sélection personnelle quand vous flirtez
avec une fille c'est pratiquement la
même chose à chaque fois mais des
partenaires enfin si quand même parce
c'est pas permis à toutes les filles je
ne peux pas ce qui les empêche on va
tous les parents leur pudeur pitou le
renouveau civière mineurs pouvaient
c'est ça aussi la comédie enceinte vous
des poudriers oui je pense que quelles
que soient les filles oui je pense oui
mais ça c'est pas les obligations
judiciaires non simulées sur vous ça va
en subir les conséquences
c'est donc parce que je suis la fille
l'a acceptée c'est qu'elle le voulait
m
[Musique]